o latitude pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
vídeo eo estrago de que vai virar e
fredes 2 este vai ser o segundo vídeo do
dia só por isso não viram o primeiro
passei por lá e deixa o vosso apoio e
bora lá então a jogar nossa segunda
noite que no fight fred pessoal eu
joguei esta noite no episódio anterior
de finados é fredes mas não é conseguir
passar porque foi muito hardcore mesmo
eu vou agora tentar passar lá então
e vamos lá ver o que o espera ok solo
preparado já foi mandar a minha poesia
da noite o tratado não está fora o spray
pela noite para jogar este jogo não é
porque é melhor eu vou dar muito caro e
eu sei que vocês não gostam que o de
musical pessoal mas ele não tem
paciência porém que o tema ela falar a
toda hora
fácil de usar a caixa agora calma lá é
omã também é pessoal tem que aguentar
até a sair vocês já sabem isto não é
mais que não eles não é isso que eu
quero fazer é ir para lá eu queria vir a
ventilação porque acho que o zé pinto
coelho foi isso
o palhaço é palhaço ok
por aqui apenas outra vez uma da manhã
da hora já avançamos favor e pessoal eu
não sei se vai acontecer
o inter manteve a calma consiga manter
não sei por que algumas vezes não
consiga se manter três cordas não saiu
da palestra ele talvez não consiga
interna eu já sei quando o inter não
funcionar aqui eu acho que sim
calma
nesta segunda à noite é muito cheio josé
pinto meu só não sabe o que está a
passar e buscar um jogo dentro do jogo
estamos usar meu é muito bizarro meu
saque manel sair daqui
coelho ok ok ok ela está pedindo ajuda
também
la paz 12 da manhã pode já acontecer
muitas coisas meu irmão foi embora
ainda hoje a corda carlos trevi que nada
o conseguir tem conseguido agora
conseguir agora anda muita coisa da luz
nada aqui
ok ok está tudo tranqüilo fred fred não
faz mal feridas vamos passar esta noite
14 amanhã eu já tocava pássaros da noite
usa palavras e palhaço bozo
calma calma sua vez ainda meu tempo não
passa o tempo não passa a internação são
miguel
agora eu viro um bolo
o álbum chegou ao restaurante porque não
conseguia mais
eu por mim agora é bizarro que eu posso
fazer agora eu não mexo mais difícil
i a sério pessoal vocês não sabem eu
fiquei que muito muito tempo só para
passar a noite dois eu concentrei me
conseguir ver o que está a passar
isso não é da noite 30 não sabem o quão
ter passado a noite e 2000 fiquei aqui
ainda mais boa hora em juvenis do meu no
trecho esta porcaria pessoal então é
isso ajude porque espera mesmo que vocês
deixem o vosso apoio pessoal e ainda
fiquei aqui há algum tempo a tentar
passar esta noite dois está muito mais
difícil do que o fábio neves e fred sun
nós é esse pessoal quando o vosso
feedback mike favorito fiquem bem até a
próxima